[Music]
Henry Cavell starring in a Monumental
sci-fi fantasy epos the new Avengers
movies are losing their most important
character and Tom Holland Spider-Man
might be getting some powerful support
in his next movie all this and more now
in this week's Koch
news it's finally official Amazon and
Games Workshop have reached an agreement
regarding the future of Warhammer 40K
and are now planning a number of films
and series together with Henry caval
right at the Forefront and Gadget states
that the deal will give Amazon exclusive
rights and Licensing to the Warhammer
40K Universe Games Workshop on the other
hand could benefit from the greater
popularity of the brand according to
Games Workshop an elite band of script
writers will come together to develop
exciting stories for upcoming films and
series they will be supported by
Superstar Henry Cavell Who as a longtime
Warhammer nerd brings a wealth of
experience to the table and will act as
executive producer it remains uncertain
whether caval will also be involved in
other upcoming projects however it is
unlikely to fail due to the actor's
interest in the topic although a
concrete adaptation of Warhammer could
still take some time information and
details are to be published as soon as
possible we are
excited shock for all comic fans Marvel
fires Kang actor Jonathan major and is
now planning to rename the next Avengers
movie the super villain Kang played by
Jonathan majors is considered one of the
most promising characters in the current
MCU and was therefore supposed to play a
central role in the upcoming movies this
is now likely to be extremely difficult
Majors was on trial being accused of
assault and domestic violence as the
court found him guilty of two out of
four charges he now faces up to a year
in prison according to the Hollywood
Reporter Marvel then fired the actor as
quick as possible fans are now asking
themselves how the MCU will continue
without Jonathan mangers as Kang on the
one hand and there is of course still
the possibility of recasting the role
this would certainly be the easiest
solution and also be nothing new in the
Marvel World Mark Ruffalo for example
slipped into the role of Bruce Banner
after creative differences arose between
the Incredible Hulk actor Edward Norton
and Marvel Don cheel also joined the MCU
later his role was played by Terrence
Howard in the very first Iron Man film
the other option however would be to
focus on a completely new villain who
could take over from Kang some time ago
rumors were already circulating the
internet that Marvel wanted to create Dr
Doom as a new antagonist the internal
renaming of Avengers the Kang Dynasty to
Simply Avengers 5 and the hiring of Loki
author Michael walren could be
indications that Marvel wants to follow
the second path as things stand Avengers
5 is still scheduled to be released in
cinemas on May 1st 2026 whether the
release date can really be complied due
to the current situation remains
questionable New Impressions of Planet
of the Apes seven years after Planet of
the Apes 3 survival the eagerly awaited
sequel is finally arriving next year
this time focusing on the ape Noah a
series of new images promises a
spectacular Adventure director West ball
revealed in Empire magazine that he
wanted to Stage a kind of Apocalypto
with apes Planet of the Apes 4 will be
the start of a new Trilogy and to set
around 300 years after the events
surrounding Caesar this time the young
chimpanzee Noah who has to deal with a
dangerous opponent called proximus
Caesar is the central figure of the
story in the course of this news a
series of further images and concept
drawings have been released giving us an
impression of the world among other
things we see Noah on his horse riding
towards a ruin accordingly there is a
Chase across a raging River in which
Noah himself appears to be in danger so
plenty of action is going to be served
the sequel is eagerly awaited especially
since the Revelation that director ball
is also set to direct the newly
announced liveaction Zelda film Kingdom
of the Planet of the Apes will be
hitting the cinemas on May 24th
2024 the rumors about the next Tom
Holland Spider-Man movie just won't stop
according to Insider Daniel Rickman we
can now expect to see two more major MCU
characters alongside the friendly spider
number one is none other than Daredevil
played by Charlie Cox the hot shot and
Spidey have already met in Spider-Man no
way home there had previously been
rumors that the two would fight Wilson
Fisk together in Spider-Man 4 the whole
thing is supposed to tie in with the new
Daredevil Born Again Series where the
mighty Kingpin basically declares the
superheroes to be criminals these rumors
seem to be substantiated as Daredevil
according to Rickman plays a major role
in the current draft of the script but
perhaps it won't just be these two
superheroes marvel is reportedly
currently considering whether Paul ruds
Antman should also join the film after
the debacle surrounding the box office
flop Ant-Man and the WASP quantum Mania
many people are wondering what the
future holds for the character anyway
besides all the magical world-saving
Multiverse stories Spider-Man 4 could be
a refreshing change of pace the
relatively reliable Insider cryptic
4wall reports that the new adventure is
set to be a kind of down to earth Civil
War in the third Captain America film of
the same name earth's greatest
superheroes split into two camps and
fought each other it is therefore quite
conceivable that one or the other of the
heroes in Spider-Man 4 will be on the
Kingpin side in a dramatic battle for
their home New York City as always of
course caution about such rumors is
advised even if the plans are true a lot
still can change at the moment not even
the positions of writer director or lead
actor have been officially confirmed Tom
Holland insists on reading a finished
script first before agreeing to another
Spider-Man film in addition to his
desire to take a break from acting the
2023 strikes have also caused the
development of the sequel to stall
Daniel Rickman also provided further
rumors they are about the MCU project of
the Young Avengers which has already
been teased at the end of the Marvels
according to The Insider the whole thing
was initially planned as a series but is
now to be developed as a movie Kevin
feige would therefore prefer to focus on
memorable events in cinematic context in
the future in addition to Kamala Khan
aka Miss Marvel and Hawkeyes Kate Bishop
Cassie Lang AKA stature is also
mentioned as a member of the Young
Avengers in an interview Miss Marvel
actress Ean valani also expressed her
wish that Miles Morales and Sam
Alexander should be starring in the film
neither of them have yet appeared in a
liveaction Marvel
series Super Mario as a musical at least
according to actor Jack Black who spoke
about the sequel of the popular video
game adaptation in an interview the
Super Mario Brothers film hit like a
bomb and with worldwide box office
takings of over $1.3 billion is
considered one of the most successful
films of 2023 so it's no wonder that the
voices regarding a sequel are getting
louder these voices include actor Jack
Black who voiced Mario's iconic
antagonist Bowser in the first part in
an interview with variety black spoke
about how he is still waiting for
Universal Pictures to finally give the
green light for a sequel black who
co-wrote the popular song Peaches is a
musician at heart as well as an actor he
said that he could well imagine Super
Mario Brothers 2 as a musical in his
opinion the sequel could take the jump
into this particular genre similar to
Todd Phillips's Joker 2 we strongly
assume that Bowser will play a role in
the new film once again whether with
vocal intrudes or not remains uncertain
until then however we're looking forward
to Jack Black's appearance and Eli
Roth's Borderlands film adaptation in
August where he borrows his voice to the
iconic robot clap
trap next year director Robert Edgars
will ensure that an absolute horror icon
will once again rise from the grave
another film adaptation of nost Fatu is
imminent the first images of the cast
have now been released originally
portrayed by Max Shrek count orlock who
was modeled on Bram Stoker's Dracula
celebrated his first big screen
appearance in 1922 in FW Mara's silent
film classic the character has been
adapted by several film producers
including verer Herzog with Claus kinsky
in the leading role over the decades now
Robert Edgars will present us with his
version of the iconic material the
director is regarded as one of the
biggest talents in the horror genre and
is particularly good when it comes to
Atmosphere films such as the witch the
lighthouse and the north man speak for
themselves a series of new images have
now been published via Entertainment
Weekly and Empire showing us the cast of
the upcoming film among others we see
Willam defo in the role of the crazy
vampire Hunter Professor Albin Eberhart
Von frons who has apparently just set an
old grave on fire also on board Lily
Rose Depp and Nicholas halt who are both
in close proximity to count orlock
indicated by his long white fingers this
time it star Bill Skarsgard slips into
the role of the gruesome count Edgar's
intuition for great images and an
oppressive atmosphere is already made
clear in the first images which is why
we are especially looking forward to the
Cinematic release of Nas veratu at the
end of
2024 attention streaming fans we can
expect numerous spin-offs of extremely
successful series including Wednesday
peaky blinders and the X s while the
second season of the Netflix hit
Wednesday starring Jenna Ortega has not
even been released yet the streaming
giant is already looking to expand the
whole thing into a franchise according
to news portal Bloomberg there are
conversations about a series centered
around Uncle Fester played by Fred Armon
in general Netflix seems to be
increasingly interested in expanding
successful Brands rather than just
focusing on new ones for example a
series based on the extraction films
with Chris Hemsworth and two spin-offs
for the popular series peaky blinders
are also being discussed one is to be
set in Boston a few decades after the
series while the other will revolve
around pully the female head of the
Shelby Clan meanwhile Disney is working
on a new xfile series while HBO is
concentrating on further Game of Thrones
variants a sequel to Sex in the City
prequels to Dune and Stephen King's it
and so on it seems that the prequel
sequel spin-off fever in movie theaters
has finally reached the streaming
platforms for good what do you think are
you happy to immerse deeper into the
well-known series or would you prefer
new Originals let us know in the
comments that sure was a lot of news but
if you're still craving for more don't
worry we'll give you more this week we
have two videos about upcoming sequels
one is the brutal action movie Mortal
Kombat 2 and the other is the long-
awaited sequel to a Disney classic of
course we're talking about zootopia 2o
other than that we are of course Keen to
hear your opinion what do you think
about the loss of the Avengers villain
and are you looking forward to the
Warhammer projects centered around Henry
Cavell we'll see you in the
[Music]
comments